Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing in
authored by
the third chapter, the chapter of
patience in the 29th narration he says,
[Silence]
This narration is on the authority of
Abi Z Abu Zade
Zade.
These two
ZB
and his son
were referred to commonly as
as the
love of the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
or the beloved of the prophet and the
son of his beloved. Zbar
was a slave
and it was a sla he was a slave who was
gifted to the prophet sallall.aii
Wasam to him by his beloved wife
before Islam.
And he essentially grew up in the
household of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam.
And as we've mentioned before, if you'll
all remember
that during the days of Jahya,
a person could become a slave in any
number of ways. It wasn't many of the
ways
or or some ways a person would become
a slave would be known. Others or many
would be illegitimate ways. So for
instance, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
mentions one of the ways of jahyah in
the Quran that a person could become a
slave
that was outlawed in Islam and outlawed
by any decent human standards.
And that is in the story of Ysefam.
You have a caravan that comes by, finds
a young boy. Instead of trying to help
this boy get home, they sell him into
slavery and into bondage.
This is a a story as old as as time as
they say.
And so oftent times you'd find people
would be slaves, grow up as slaves, be
purchased and sold as slaves.
And it would not be really known how
this person became a slave.
Perhaps this person was found as a small
child and even kidnapped and sold into
slavery. Perhaps a person owes debt
and they give their child
up into slavery in place of this
debt.
Or perhaps a people are
overpowered by another tribe and
their sons will be sold into slavery
etc. Many many different ways
in Islam
it was reversed. This whole process was
reversed.
There's only one way a person can
legitimately become a slave and that is
that they are captured on the
battlefield actively fighting against
the Muslim and they are taken as PS
prisoners of war
and there are many many ways of becoming
free as a matter of fact one of the most
common
encouragements throughout the Quran and
Sunnah is freeing slaves. slaves.
Why? In order to give people the best
opportunity and and to lean towards
the tendency of mercy.
However,
just absolute emancipation or if the
prophet sallall.aii wasallam came and
said no more slavery in Islam or
you know all slaves must be freed
immediately. This would have shocked the
economy at the time. This would have put
a lot of slaves out of a home cuz not
all of them were ready to become free.
And so
is one of those cases.
Hara was purchased by
he was gifted. She gifted Z to her
husband the prophet Muhammad
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam before he
was a prophet
and he grew up in the prophet's home
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
and when
Z became older and the prophet
himself became older sai wasam and he
had other children
suddenly one day
the tribe of Zed show
And a man named Hara shows up. Who is
Hara? He says that he is Zade's father.
So we can surmise that somehow Zade
found his way into the system as a
slave. Legitimately or illegitimately,
we do not know. But we know that once he
was u of age and able to able to make
his own decisions, his uncle and his
father showed up one day and said, "This
is our son. You have our son here."
And so the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam. This is before prophethood.
Before he was a prophet, he made them a
very reasonable deal.
He said, "If Zade wants to go with you,
I'll let him go. And if he wants to
stay, I'll let him stay." And so Zade
who chose to stay with the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam.
Upon making that choice, the prophet
freed him and adopted him as his son.
Now adoption at that time in Jahia
it was full adoption. When you adopt
a boy, it meant that this boy takes your
name, takes your lineage, and takes all
the rulings of a biological son. This is
the way they did it in Jahya.
And so this is incorrect.
And as kind as this may be to one
person, it is disruptive of lineage. It
is disruptive of many other things and
balances that Allah insists must be
kept. And so he was always referred to
from that point on as Zin Muhammad. And
this was a great honor for him even
before Islam. Even before the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam was a prophet.
We fast forward through the years and
Zade has is married to Zanab
and Zade has a son of his own and he
names his son Usama. Now
was
and
in the position of his grandson,
right? as was the case in the time of
Jiley with with regards to the the
traditions of
adoption. And so he was referred to
as Usam Zbin Muhammad and his father was
Zbin Muhammad. And they referred to to
them or he would refer to them as
that he was the beloved of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam, the son of his
beloved. They were very close.
We fast forward and when we look at the
Quran, we see that many companions were
mentioned by description. Many of them
Abu Bakr
is mentioned by description in some
estimates as being over 30 times or even
more by description.
However, by name,
no companions were mentioned by name.
And
when the time around the time of
around the we're not sure exactly
what year but somewhere between the
fifth and seventh year after hijra
adoption became prohibited in Islam
and anyone who was adopted
he was to be referred referred to by his
biological father. No more reference to
an adopted father's lineage. No more
claim to an adopted father's lineage. It
doesn't mean that whoever had adopted a
son or a daughter, they threw him out in
the street. It doesn't mean that. It
just means that the lineage and the
rulings of the adopted
are not the same as the rulings of a
biological child. Right? And so
one of those people or we could actually
say two of those people who were greatly
affected by this was Z and his son Usama
because he was always referred to as
Zbin Muhammad. Now that's a great honor
and then suddenly the honor is taken
away from him. It would seem
and so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
insisted that the laws of adoption as
practiced in
be done away with and be eradicated. And
the best way to do that is not just to
abstractly
change the laws, but to have the prophet
himself practice the correct way in
order that all these taboss be
abolished. And one of those was, as we
said, a biological son
takes the or a an adopted son in Jahia
takes the rulings of a biological son.
And so just you could not marry
your biological son's divorce.
Likewise, a man could not marry his
biological son's divorce, divorced wife.
Likewise
in Jahya it was incredibly taboo for a
man to marry his adopted sons divorce.
And so Zan
prior to being
she was divorced by
divorced by Zb
and the prophet sallall.aii wasallam was
commanded to marry Zanab. He wasn't
allowed to marry Zanab. He was commanded
by Allah to marry Zanab. And Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala said
that Allah himself is the one who
married Zanab to the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. She was the only one of his
wives that he was married to without
a guardian. her guardian was
considered to be Allah himself subhanahu
wa ta'ala and Zanab found that point of
pride for her and so
in this action
this was abolished
adoption in the way that it was
practiced in the time of Jahya and
slavery in the way that it was practiced
in Jahya
in one act was abolished.
However, we still have
seemingly
suffering a loss in this whole
issue. Why? Because he was called
Zadbin Muhammad and now he is referred
to as Zinhita.
And it almost seems he is his his
lineage is displaced overnight for no
fault of his own. And so Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
mentioned
by name in
he is the only companion mentioned by
name in all of the Quran.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
And so we see that zade as as a
as a substitute or in order to not
have him feel any kind of way. his his
his name is no longer Z Muhammad but
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala gave him
something better than that and that is
that he mentioned his name and he's the
only companion mentioned by name in the
Quran and so
is now referred to as Zbar
however he is also the only companion
mentioned by name in the Quran in
so his name is mentioned in the Quran as
a substitute or as a replacement for
what was taken from him. And so these
two are known as
known as the beloved of the prophet, the
son of his, the beloved, the son of his
beloved. And both of them have a very
illustrious history in Islam and with
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam. We'll
mention in more detail tomorrow.
Subhanah.
Subhanahu wa ta'ala.